hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the blind smartphone camera
test 2019. so this idea really started
last year when i wanted to do a test of
all the best smartphone cameras really
find out which one the best is and i
could have just done pixel versus iphone
at the time but i also wanted to throw
in the new samsung phone but then maybe
people want to see like a oneplus and it
eventually just turned into
let's just include them all let's just
throw them all in there so from that the
blind camera test was born and if you've
been following along on twitter and
instagram for about the past week you've
seen that we've done it again this year
and the results i think are fascinating
so the format is as you may remember we
took
16 smartphones we set up a bracket of
all of them sort of seated in a way
and then got to work so here's the
competitors this year we have google
pixel 4
iphone 11 pro samsung galaxy note 10
google pixel 3a samsung galaxy s10e
oneplus 7t pro oneplus 7t huawei mate 30
pro huawei p30 pro the 108 megapixel
xiaomi mi note 10 sony xperia 1 redmi
k20 pro lg g8x then q asus rog phone 2
asus zenfone 6 and the royal flex pi so
as you can tell a pretty healthy variety
of flagships from the smartphones that
you'd probably consider favorites in a
test like this down to some mid-range
phones some budget ones and just some
random ones thrown in there and my
favorite part of this is there's so many
cameras there's so many options that
it's impossible to like
narrow it down to like oh i know what
iphone photos look like so i'll vote for
the iphone every time there's no way for
you to know it's totally blind so we
went out and we matched them all up from
the bracket and we took the photos with
all 16 phones again keeping in mind
consistency and including things in the
photos that people typically take photos
of skin tones for sure fabrics for
textures different colors dynamic range
with the sky in the background a subject
with a foreground and a background etc
and every single one was just the
default open the camera tap a face take
a photo with the exception of the xiaomi
mi note 10 which we'd open the camera
app switch to the 108 megapixel mode and
then take the photo because that's the
whole reason we included it so we
assigned each phone a letter a all the
way through p and then we started
stitching them together and matching
them up so every single one would have a
match up one round at a time so we
conducted the tests again the polling on
instagram stories and on twitter so
we're thankfully allowed to use images
in polls in tweets again on twitter so
shout out to them for allowing us to do
that for this test so four million
instagram votes later and two million
twitter votes later
we have our winners
so
this is the bracket so these are the
phones that were behind each of the
letters so without checking twitter this
is the fun part go ahead and pause this
video and fill out this bracket march
madness style the way you think it will
actually go based on votes you can even
use your information about what happened
in last year's blind test to better
inform your decision so really this is
your shot go ahead fill it out this is
your chance
and now without any further ado let me
show you exactly how it went down so
round one just a photo of me a human we
had the asus zenfone 6 absolutely crush
the oneplus 7t
then we had huawei mate 30 pro defeating
asus rog phone 2
then
note 10 plus easily beating the royal
flex pi as you might have predicted and
then the pixel 3a beat the lg
g8x then on the other side galaxy s10e
beat the 108 megapixel xiaomi mi note 10
the oneplus 7t pro beat the iphone 11
pro
pixel 4
beat the sony sperry 1 and last but not
least redmi k20 pro beat huawei p30 pro
so a very interesting start
none of these interestingly was even
close every single one was a blowout the
closest one was actually the redmi over
the huawei which was about 150 000 to 90
000 on instagram so pretty convincing in
every single first round photo some of
these i'd say were expected some of
these were definitely still in the
category of upsets but we'll get to all
that in a bit
round two so this is the photo of the
hot sauce got some warm and cool tones
in there there's skin tones there's a
subject with a slightly blurred
background and there's some sharp text
to read in the middle so in this round
mate 30 pro
narrowly beat the zenfone 6 then below
that we had note 10 plus which overcame
the pixel 3a then on the other side
samsung galaxy s10e moved on over
oneplus 7t pro
and pixel 4
beat the k20 pro
so again some interesting stuff actually
before all of this even happened i
filled out sort of my own bracket of
what i predicted i thought would win and
i had mate 30 pro carrying a torch to
the end for a repeat of the finals like
last year but other than that
i got a lot of this stuff wrong and i
feel like you may have too
um weird stuff but still kind of up for
grabs on to the next one so round three
was the roadster die cast model photo
plenty of colors on purpose uh the
subject and the background is a little
out of focus again skin tones and or
outdoors and in this round the samsung
galaxy note 10 plus beat the mate 30 pro
and on the other side
the samsung galaxy s10e
beat
the pixel 4.
oh
right
okay so i guess this uh
we probably should have expected this
putting essentially the same camera on
both sides of the bracket but i guess
you could say we also did that with
pixel 3a and pixel four but literally
we didn't expect them to meet the finals
maybe you did
but that's what happened so the finals
was essentially the same camera pitted
against itself which i i just took as a
landscape photo out the window not a
whole ton of variety because i sort of
figured it wouldn't matter anyway but
the galaxy note 10 eventually ended up
winning by a healthy amount here so
there you have it that's the final
bracket some weird wild results mixed in
but a lot of the same principles from
last year's blind test were still on
display here plus one new one was
interesting to see
so last year what did we find well
basically that when you put two
smartphone photos next to each other on
social media where everything is very
much compressed essentially sharpness
now matters a lot less detail matters
less textures matter less even contrast
almost doesn't matter essentially when
all else is the same and you put them
right next to each other people are
gonna just pick the brighter photo
this
has not changed and a lot of that
explains the first two rounds of this
really well basically in the camera app
for all of these we just tapped on my
face very consistently for every single
photo and some brought the exposure up a
little more others often the good ones
brought it up a little bit but kept more
of the background in the shot with more
dynamic range so really just the ones
that brightened me up the most tended to
win the weird fluke to me was the iphone
11 pro that i actually think lost
because of white balance for whatever
reason when the iphone 11 misses it's
more this year than ever before it
really goes cool and this one missed
blue and we even took multiple photos
from the iphone thinking it was kind of
odd that it was so blue like this but
that's the way they all turned out and
naturally the warmer more accurate photo
from the oneplus took that round so
again through round two the voting
margins got a bit closer because the
photos are in this controlled
environment where they are closer
looking but generally the same theme
prevailed if there was one significantly
brighter than the other it won by more
votes but then this is actually where i
started to find something else something
new starting in this round and people
were actually starting to reply and type
and comment that they were doing this
people started voting for the photo
that just had more in focus so in this
photo mate 30 pros on the top
note 10 is on the bottom not much of a
difference in brightness or color so
people started pixel peeping a little
bit and you can clearly tell the
background is more blurred in the top
photo you know the color chart my
sneakers the green chair behind me all
of it is blurrier behind it which made
people vote for
the bottom this is kind of backwards
because we generally like a soft
out-of-focus background that's a more
expensive look that's typically coming
out of full-size cameras with much
bigger sensors that's why we have
portrait mode on these smartphones to
sort of fake that look with the tiny
sensors we have in these but even among
smartphone cameras some sensors are
bigger than others and so if you know
huawei stuff you know they're one of the
ones to stuff a massive sensor in their
phone which is why even without portrait
mode on the subject is in focus the same
way and the background is more blurred
than some other smartphone sensors so
now you know when you put two photos
next to each other
comparing them brings up these
tendencies in people where apparently
the masses decided that they would
select the photo with more in focus as
better even though technically speaking
it's in theory worse because it's a
telltale sign of a smaller sensor if we
look at the other side of the bracket
you can see the same thing now in this
case the s10e on top is also a bit
brighter than the pixel 4 at the bottom
so that's going to give it a bit of an
advantage off the start but even still
putting these photos next to each other
where the pixel 4 at the bottom
clearly
clearly took a better photo it's more
neutral there's more accurate colors
more dynamic range there's no blown
highlights on the red of the roadster
more accurate skin tones and a softer
shallower depth of field to top it all
off but people picked the top photo 140
000 to 80 000 on instagram now i do have
to give some of you photographers and
fellow youtubers and keynote people some
credit because you did see that clearly
the bottom photo was better and you
couldn't believe that the top photo was
winning and i'm with you and even though
i knew which one was which even if you
looked at each individual photo by
itself you can tell clearly the bottom
photo was better so of course we know
you and me we definitely know that when
you're comparing a high quality photo
versus a slightly lower quality photo
the bigger sensor the one with the
blurred background that's something to
look out for
but you know not not everyone not the
four million voters you know they might
not know that so anyway that gives us
our finals that's the galaxy note 10
plus and the galaxy s10e and what
happened here what what exactly went
down that a landscape photo from two
nearly identical camera suites gave us
such a dramatic winner well actually
it's pretty simple i was taking this
photo through a window i took it on the
silver galaxy note 10 plus
and the pink galaxy s10e and if you look
at these photos the s10e photo is kinda
magenta shifted at the bottom half
because it's literally reflecting the
pink phone back at me that i'm taking
the picture with now if i didn't have
that glass in front of me who knows what
else people would have looked for to
pick a winner between two presumably
nearly identical photos but to be fair
to give you guys credit you did see that
good spot so what did we learn from all
this well one
people still like
brighter photos two when presented with
two photos of similar brightness people
tend to prefer the photo with more in
focus you know it may seem like more
detail but it's essentially a sign of a
worse photo but people didn't care and
then three
people make some fascinating decisions
and observations when presented with
side by sides like this so either way
that's been it congrats to the samsung
galaxy note 10 plus your winner of the
second annual people's choice blind
smartphone camera bracket
um and yeah maybe maybe we'll feel even
a little bit different about this later
this year when twitter's now stopping
compression of jpeg photos and full-size
photo viewing you never know the
landscape could be shaken up again but
either way until the next one
catch you guys later
peace
[Music]